how's it going bros my name is bad bad
have you missed me have you mentioned of
course I miss you bros a lot it's been a
long time
sure a lot of you like what's this cuz
this person I'm subscribed to anyway
I'm Peter if I just told you Jesus
Christ I can have a memory problem let's
play well of his demise demeanor and I
saying
to be honest you play a school laugh and
your laugh I would
hello they all laugh and you're a mate
oh and your house may be haunted so be
careful alright maybe I think it's
haunted
just my intuition I'm door trained a lot
of you bros has said yes to this one
it's supposed to be really scary so I'm
looking forward playing it might sound
this weird weight loss again I think my
headphones were [ __ ] up in there when
I travel with them whatever here we are
I know
hey get out of my face
Jesus Christ I'm Olaf I run this place
what I told I told them to fix this
yesterday Jesus Christ I waited to
friggin weeks for you Jesus Christ
Caramba nice beard you got to go in
there yes I grew it during the holidays
do you like it I want it to be Santa
class you can test fine sign the car
white is still stuck Jesus Christ back
now there you go I thought he didn't
bring alright whatever you been up to
I've been in you know that are you mark
hey hey I didn't mean to throw him let's
just look at the ass I got - all right
let's pick up some stuff before it oh
yes oh oh oh no oh no no bro why would
he do potatoes oh nice
why would he Jesus cries you were scared
from a poo file you should know better
bite Napoli all right let's go up this
creep the car tire actually it's not
really a car door it's two stairs
whatever just keep walking that broke on
me good I've been pleading wise I guess
I'm I'll be more scared or something all
right it's gonna put you down
don't slow down Jesus Christ Oh oh yeah
I have the key don't worry I don't have
the landing though that's the problem
I'll just wait there Stefano I'll be
right there
all right we gotta find the lantern
stuff I don't want to pick up any more
keys
no but take it out stop hiding from me I
know it all of your plans
where's the [ __ ] lantern all right
here we go
here's a house
[Music]
hey didn't box
all right where's the [ __ ] lantern
give it to me give it to me give it to
me mr. Sherr get out all right
you're not mrs. Sharon Sunny Boy yeah
can we give us something good Jesus cry
it make me LuAnn halogen yeah
piggy yeah I'm so frigging Bob look at
me eight I'm being cookie out waiting to
be cooked and then you come out G scram
show pump oh oh you like that barrels
you like that that's right you know oh
man I miss you so much hallo Bros how
y'all doing I miss you so much you have
no idea 14 days I've been not right is
this thing Nora piggy might have I just
need to find a frickin Jesus Christ
don't tell me it's here I'm gonna
pitched I don't think it's uh it's stuck
it's got a bit though here somewhere I
think there what do you want from me a
mice hey there we go all right oh my god
what the [ __ ] let me pick up my land
without dad party naked guys I hate
Jesus Christ
- heart attacks already got down God
all right I think I can go here now
[ __ ] camera still up JIT all right
yeah there you are an idiot I heard you
screaming like a girl there Jessica oh
wow it really is a difference if you
don't know why all right we need to find
the [ __ ] something seriously I don't
why I wouldn't be serious about it Jesus
Christ it's gotta be here somewhere not
the piano bass how about Petey yeah you
know 14 days without doing anything you
know that it makes me really excited you
know it makes me just want to run on
this barrel and just stroke my penis
against it like it I call this a barrel
room you like that you like the barrel
you like when the barrel squeeze me
you like that Petey you like that I like
that you know if you want to some days
you you and me in the barrel
why do you barrels I will never good
spell I hope it's not behind these hey
Stanley
yeah there's Subway's singer okay sorry
Basque [ __ ] out of here it's not here
why the [ __ ] is the [ __ ] key oh here
we go here we go all right I got it
all right Stefano I'll be right there
okay Pitt a wino oh yeah okay and then
we got our genius she fits my geniusness
what is this I hate to say this but be
prepared when you enter really I don't
like it Mikey broke when I used to make
ma B there's another key down there I
don't trust this place what are you
doing here Jennifer
Jesus Christ you're huge why am I
talking with stuff all the way right
I don't like this I just go here hello
hello Oh No [ __ ] that's in a box yeah
I'll out in about my 8 you there but
they're protecting boughs move away from
me no all right we get but what are you
doing they're trying to hide
stupid court I hate you Jennifer I love
you so much I missed you so much for two
each oh my god it's crazy 9:00 a.m. yeah
yeah all right what are we doing we need
to find a [ __ ] key there we go oh
wait someone's gonna do something Hey
way all right cool I'm just gonna pick
up this magma of or it could be a lot of
cheese doodles smashed into a big cheese
doodle do you like it was it tasty
now me all right leave that she's doing
Oh No
I need some fun on here [ __ ] mattress
all right bro they do we need to find
the other part of the bro what is it oh
no doggy
I'm dead all right and he's gonna go oh
no this is the cousin sorry for me I
know you picked that I found the cellar
key maybe I can open it oh no I love
spitting I waited for you and down and
made it I don't know why but I had no
idea this was for me I swear a lot of
people are complaining you only play
custom stories made for you I'm sorry I
really had no that's awesome like I mean
maybe or maybe not I don't know that
means the file is pretty famous what are
you talking about of course I'm famous
Jesus Christ you don't want anything
I am [ __ ] French when I was in when I
was younger they I was you did not get
far no I I didn't get any way by the way
I know I said I was gonna offer this the
seven of January but might I come back
and my [ __ ] internet doesn't work and
they say at 14 weeks without my computer
and Internet it's like mmm I've been
crawling the walls and then I come back
it doesn't work and I like I don't know
it wasn't very nice I want me it's
alright with all your LSPD how you doing
here where did that thing go barrels
alright let's just keep going
all right this way payday of course I
know don't talk to Jennifer she's ugly
no don't say that she has feelings too
father I know I was with a long time
Jesus Christ when we broke you words
with Jennifer yes but don't tell anyone
what did I tell oh okay yee-yee a
Charlotte Ashley we're just loading
screen so weird I hate to say this but
be prepared when you enter what is this
what the [ __ ] I'm tapped out bad okay
now now boxes don't know how out my head
Jesus Christ
alright ah Jesus Christ
let's just go the house
that's not even barrel where's the
father
oh no oh no we lost gone up all right
this is go I don't like this how much
let's go I don't it's impossible trust
this card alright which key you the old
key right no why did you tell me you
just sit there do nothing actually if
you want to you can open this [ __ ]
door
okay let's disk this is bad
all right just take it really easy
anyone Wow oh man ah I know I wasn't
tougher stupid stupid
this is place red light on no that's
never good news all right
I'll just shake out barrels Hey nope
okay you go first mr. chair but did
nothing
what about this pot go damn it
all right bro I'm just gonna go here if
you don't mind it's gonna read this well
buck yeah right next to the delicious
meals on this hand wherever we'll had
these meals oh it's a finger well it's
lovely
well can we throw it up Wow oh I didn't
mean through that that wasn't me I'm
sorry bro sorry I ruined your meal
all right or laugh if you read this I
think something is in your house I mean
look at the dining plates I'm so scared
I'm so scared
I love solving in his room that my hell
all right let's find that's a little
something I'd say then here nah is it in
here not that is it uh here yes I know
I'm a genius
oh no that does not sound good
that was my mom coming home for
breakfast what what do you think all
right
oh no wait Stefano I don't like you very
much you know that I don't like your
style
you're out of fashion this was in about
like 800 years ago I waited for you baby
I was just bored if you were born I'll
let no I wasn't what makes you think
that I'd look like a ma I'm I don't even
know what to say
what the [ __ ] hey dolly oh no these guys
did drugs and had gangbang and then they
died that's the only conclusion I can
the mushroom made the mushrooms and then
the gangbang oh right oh Jesus Christ
you're all disgrace there's no women
here all gave the gangbang
that's what you get to feed mushrooms
gets don't need mushrooms I mean you
could eat regular mushrooms I think
maybe I don't forget that oh let's go
with the gangbang let's go back to the
gaming all right
sorry gaming us sorry about what I said
earlier
I just want to chill out here for a
minute just until he goes away all right
don't mind me though you can keep doing
the gangbang stuff or just being bad
that works too
you can just stay that if you want just
gonna shag you should steer here hello
I heard mommy sat you mom are we good
all right perfect
oh they have gangbang here too
days it's best Matt stop scaring me like
I better I need a [ __ ] to keep the
go-ahead Jason's penis freakin gag man
you should have told me
[ __ ] Jesus penis it was you all along
wasn't it Matt and your friends I see
that French don't try to hide you
[ __ ] it up
I'm stuck know that bad what is this
place oh damn hmm [ __ ] cousin story
like jump scares every [ __ ] minute
alright I promise the next time I will
do a serious cost to society I mean this
is serious all but really all right
let's go here and the next episode
flying favorites if you have to the
house back I'm really glad to be back
and I'll see ya tomorrow I'm back on
track I'm with making videos hopefully
if I [ __ ] in there I can't wait anyway
that's pretty much it
[Music]
[Music]
you